good morning everyone and welcome to the
next video from simply learn
in this video we are going to discuss
sql injection and the types of sql
injection
this is what is going to be covered in
this video
the first point will be we will be
discussing what exactly is sql injection
then we'll discuss the types of sql
injection how does sql work on a website
so sql is a structured query language
we'll be discussing that a little bit
and how to prevent sql injection we'll
be looking at basic pointers on what to
utilize so that sequential is not
possible
and then we'll be looking at a couple of
demos during this video
on sql injection so let's begin with
what is sql injection
as the name suggests sql injection
vulnerability allows an attacker to
inject malicious input into a
sql statement so sql stands for
structured query language which is a
language used by an application to
interact with the database
now normally this attack is targeted
towards a database to extract
the data that is stored within however
the vulnerability does not lie in the
database itself
the vulnerability will always lie in the
application
it is the developer's prerogative of how
to develop the application how to
configure it
to prevent sql injection queries from
happening
a database is created to answer
questions and if a question is asked
it is supposed to answer it database
needs to be configured
for some amount of security but the
vulnerability the flaw here for sql
injection
will always lie in the application
itself it does how the application
interacts
with the database that needs to be
modified that needs to be maintained by
the developer
rather than just configuring the
database itself so the attacker at this
point in time
when they send a query to the
application will form
a malformed query by injecting a
particular command or an operator that
is recognized by the sql language
and if that operator is passed through
the application to the database
then the database basically gets cracked
or
does a data dump because of that
unwanted character coming in
so this character needs to be filtered
at the application level itself now
let's look at a quick demo so what we
have done here is
i have this virtual machine called ovasp
broken web applications virtual machine
version 1.2
i'm going to power this on
till this power is on i'm going to show
you where we can download this
uh utility from so you can just
look for wasp broken web application
project
download you'll find it on
sourceforge.net click on the link
you can download the broken web
application project from here
this is a 1.9 gb download and you can
have a
zip machine directly for vmware or every
oracle virtual box
now this is an application that has been
developed by owasp which stands for open
web application security project
which is a not-for-profit organization
and
periodically releases the most top 10
risks
that an application will face for that
particular
year so they have given a web
application
with inbuilt vulnerabilities for
professionals like us to practice upon
to develop
our skills upon because doing this in
the real world
is illegal i cannot go on to a website
to demonstrate how a sequel injection
attack works
neither should you try your hands on it
till you become very
well rehearsed with it so till uh to
upgrade your skills to upskill yourself
please download this machine host it in
a vmware workstation
or an oracle virtual box and you can uh
then try your skills on it
right so just going back to the browser
here if i
open up uh a new tab you will see that
this machine has booted up and has an ip
address called 71.132
so if i just go on to that ip address
and i type in 192
168 71.132
and you'll see the os broken web
application project and there are a lot
of training applications
realistic intentionally vulnerable
applications old versions of real
applications and so on so forth
so there is a lot of applications in
built over here that you can
try your skills upon we are going to try
to use the ovas
mutility over here uh this gives you the
os top 10 risks for 2010 2013
2017 is the latest one so far but
the difference between 2013 and 2017 is
that some
of these have changed but not all of
them uh the order has changed a little
bit but you can see that sequel
injection is
on the top a1 amongst the injection
attacks
right and you can see there are multiple
types that have been given here the
sequel injection for extracting data
or sql injection for bypass
authentication or
insert your injection attacks blind sql
injection
and then there is a tool called sql map
which is available freely on
your linux machines kali linux or parrot
linux whichever you want to use
for your practice targets and so on so
forth so
if i just take you here for bypass
authentication
and this is a regular login page that an
application may
have right you look at a username you
like a password
you type that in and you log in so let's
say i don't know
a password here i'm just going to type
in the username test password is psswrd
i try to log in and it shows me that the
account does not exist so the
authentication mechanism does
work i did try typing a username and
password it wasn't recognized so the
account does not exist
now let's try to type in a sql query
here i'm going to just give it a single
quote which is an operator that is
recognized by the sql language
which when the database tries to execute
uh will cause the database to
dump some data or to bypass
authentication in this case
and i'm going to give it a condition
single quote
or one equals one
space hyphen iphone space and i'm going
to click on login
now right now i'm not logged in at all
and we tried our username and password
and we weren't able to log in so now if
i log in
you will see that it give me a status
update saying the user has been
authenticated
and i'm logged in as admin got root so
that
is what these sql queries can achieve
i'm going to log out right now and uh
we're going to look
at the basics of sql injection so
looking at that small demo
looking now let's look at what types of
secure injections are available
so the first is in-band sql injection
the
there are two sub-types within in-band
error-based injection attack and a union
based injection attack
the second type is blind sequel
injection attack where there's a boolean
based and a time-based attack
and the third one is a out-of-bound sql
injection attack
now what is in-band sql injection attack
in band is where
we are either attempting the error-based
or the union based what is error-based
we send a query to the database we craft
a query to the database
and uh it generates an error miss
message and it dumps the error message
right in front of us on the screen
that makes us realize that there is a
flaw
and there is some information that is
dumped on the screen
which we can then further utilize to
craft our further queries
as we go ahead whereas union base
is the it is where we combine multiple
statements at the same time so if you
look at the url
uh earlier in the url you would see a
large structure
in that url uh we can try to add more
two or more statements within the url
itself to combine them and then confuse
the database into executing both the
statements together
and giving a data dump at the same time
right
so what would an error-based sql
injection look like if i go back to the
same database
uh which is here right and if you
remember the username we gave it a
single quote or one equals one space
hyphen iphone space
we gave it the condition right so
basically what it did was
a single quote is an operator that goes
to the database selects the default
uh table in the user tables in this
database column
and then compares it to the condition
that is given so the condition that we
gave was
1 equals 1 which is always true so what
it did was
it selected the default user table that
was available
in the database and instead of comparing
it to a password it compared it to the
condition
so if i give it one equals two where the
condition is false
and if i log in you will see that the
account doesn't exist
comes back again because the condition
was false and instead of comparing the
user account to the password it
basically
compared the user account to the
condition so if i give it a single quote
or one equals one iphone iphone space
and log in you can see that this is a
correct
condition and thus we are able to log in
now
before we even go to that extent if i
just forget the condition over here and
just give it a single quote the operator
and i send this operator to the database
and i click on login
you will see that it generates an error
which is right on top
and it tells us the line the file where
the error happened
and you can see it happened in the
mysqlhandler.php file
right and then it gave us the message
you have an error
in your sql syntax check the manual that
corresponds to your
mysql server version for the right
syntax to use
now why would a hacker want to do this
in the first place because there are
different types of databases
so there is a mysql ms sql or microsoft
sql
oracle sql ibm db2 all of these are
variations of the sql database
they use the sql language however every
database has its own command right there
they have their own syntax they have
their own
uh specific commands that are utilized
for the database
so in this scenario the hacker wants to
identify what database is being
currently utilized so they can craft
those particular queries
so now with this injection with just me
sending the quote and the error getting
generated i now come to know that we
are using a mysql server and the version
of that server is 5.1.73
and the rest of the information about
where the
handlers are located and so on so forth
right this gives the information to the
hacker of how they want to proceed next
what kind of queries they want to create
what kind of syntax they want to utilize
so
error base attack is where you generate
these kind of errors
uh and you get this information the
union base is where you craft your
queries
within the url uh you can try to
combine multiple statements within the
input fields
and try to generate a response from that
when we come to boolean based sql
injection
sends a sql query to the database which
forces the application to return a
different
result depending on whether the query
returns a true or a
false result so basically if
the input is false the input both the
inputs are false the output would be
false
there's one input that is false the
other input that is true input b
the output would be true and so on so
forth right so depending on the result
from the inputs the attacker will come
to know which input is true
with this he can then access the
database of the website so you're trying
to figure out
by sending out multiple inputs and then
analyzing the output to see what exactly
which command exactly worked what was
the resultant
output of that command thus from this
kind of an information the hacker can
infer
their next step forward then you have
time based sql injections
uh now there are times when a database
administrator or an application
administrator has
done some security configuration and
does
have disabled verbose error messages now
what is a verbose error message
the error message that we saw right here
is a verbose error message that means
that the message
gives out details the message gives out
details about
what the database is the version and
whatnot so
if they have sanitized these errors
and you no longer can generate these
errors and thus you cannot figure out
what database is then what do you do
right
for example if i just take you to
simplylearn
and
take you to a url that is supposedly not
accessible
you can see that it gives a generic
error oops like
it looks like you have crash landed on
mars it doesn't give you a
verbose error that we saw here so this
gives us a detail error of what went
wrong where
it gives us the database the version of
the database and
uh where the query went wrong and etc
etc etc
whereas on this side where there's some
there's a lot of security that goes in
here so you can see that
it doesn't generate a error
you just get a generic page in front of
you so in that case what does a hacker
do
so the hacker then injects a time-based
query in the url which allows us
to verify whether the command is being
executed or not so
we put in a time wait let's say 10
seconds of time wait so if we
the moment we inject the query if the
query
times for 10 seconds and then gets
executed that means that
the sequel injection is possible however
if we inject the query and it just gets
executed without the delay
that means that the time injection
attack would not be
uh possible on that particular site out
of bound is not a very common attack it
depends on the features being there
enabled in the database management
system that has been used by the web
application so this can be a somewhat of
a misconfiguration error
by the database administrator where you
have enabled functions
and not sanitize them so you have not
done in
access controls properly you have not
given account control so
queries should never be executed at an
administrative level
they should always be executed at a user
level
with minimum privileges that are
required for that query to be executed
now if you're allowing these kind of
functions
to be to be enabled at the dbms and
there is an administrative account that
can have access to them
at that point in time and out of bound
injection attack is
possible so let's look at how a website
works
right uh how sql works on a website now
the website is constructed of html
hypertext markup language uh which would
include java scripting for functionality
cascading style sheets
for the mapping of the website right and
then
react.js and whatnot for further
functionality
now when we send a query to the website
it is normally
using the http protocol on https
protocol
when the query reaches the application
the application would then go ahead and
generate the
sql query at the client side you'll have
all these scripting languages coming in
on the front end
that we can utilize to craft queries and
then send them across
at the server side you'll have databases
like oracle mysql ms sql and so on so
forth that will then execute those
queries
right so just to give you an example
if i use a tool called postman
what we generally do uh when we craft a
query is we send out a
get request to the website
and then we receive a response from the
site uh with the html code and
everything
so this is a tool that is utilized by
software testers to
test the responses that you're going to
get from various websites
so on the left hand side you can see
i've used it on quite a bit
uh here we have an example for gmail.com
so let's continue with that
so this is a get request being sent to
gmail the moment i send it it's going to
create an http request
and send it across the response that i
get is this this is the html code for
gmail.com
right these are the cookies these are
the headers
that include information so you can see
this is a text html
character set utilized is utf-8 and the
configuration
uh that has been done with the
application right so this is where
uh everything comes in this is the
cookie that has been sent with that
particular
uh request that i had sent out now if
you analyze
this query right so when we went on to
this application and i typed in that
single quote and we generated this error
right uh you can see that the
application converted this
into a sql query so the query was select
username from accounts where the
username
in quote single quotes and we use this
quote right
the single quote right there so
uh that's where we use that operator and
that's where the exception error
occurred
so these are the kind of queries that
are structured by the application
and then taken on to the database for
execution
when we type in uh it is a http get
request
with the username and password within
that query that is sent to the
application the application converts it
into a
sql query sends it to the database and
the database responds with the
appropriate response
so how do we prevent sequel injection in
the first place
use prepared statement and parameterize
queries
these statements make sure that the
parameters pass into sql statements are
treated in a safe manner
so for example we saw that the single
quote was an operator
this shouldn't be allowed to be utilized
in the first place
right so here what we are doing here is
a secure way of running a sql query in
the jdbc using a parameterized statement
define which user we want to find so
there's a string the email comes in
connection to the database we are going
to figure out how the connection is
going to be passed how it is going to be
created
construct the sql statement we want to
run specifying the parameter
right so we define how is it going to be
uh created what is going to be created
what can be passed to the database and
what should not be passed to the
database
so that is one way of utilizing prepared
statements and parameterized queries
then we have object relational mapping
most development
uh teams prefer to use objection object
relational mapping frameworks to make
the translation of sql results
set into code objects more seamless so
this is an example
of object relational mapping uh where we
map
certain objects and allow that to be
executed
and then escaping inputs in a simple way
to protect against most sql injection
attacks many languages have standard
functions
to achieve this right so you need to be
very careful while using escape
characters in your code base when a sql
statement is constructed
not all injection attacks rely on abuse
of code characters
so you need to know what characters are
being utilized
uh in the configuration that you have
created in the structure that you have
created in the code that you have
created
uh which characters are being recognized
as operators
you need to sanitize those operators and
you need to
basically ensure that these operators
cannot be
accepted as user input if they are
they're faded out by the application and
they never reach the
database other methods of preventing sql
injection are
password hashing so that passwords
cannot be bypassed the passwords cannot
be recovered passwords cannot be cracked
uh third-party authentication you use
oauth
or some other service for a single
sign-on mechanism
does you rely on a third party
to maintain the security of
authentication and
what kind of parameters are passed for
example
uh using linkedin logins or facebook
logins right
for the layman you normally go on to
facebook and you allow
if you're using a game right if you
start playing a game you're allowed to
log into the game using your facebook
credentials
or your google credentials now that is
not just for ease of use
but the game user the developer has
outsourced the authentication mechanisms
to third party such as facebook or
google because they
understand that that authentication
mechanism is
as safe as can be facebook and google
are wealthy organizations
uh hire a lot of security experts and
the development for their authentication
mechanisms is top-notch
small organization cannot spend that
kind of money on security itself right
so you use a third-party authentication
mechanism to ensure that
these kind of attacks may not happen
then web application firewalls
uh having a web application firewall and
configuring it properly
for sql injection attacks is one of the
sure shot method
of mitigating or minimizing the
uh threat in the first place so at this
point in time you have realized that the
application has some vulnerabilities for
sql injection
and instead of recoding or restructuring
the application
uh you want to take the easier way out
or the cheaper way out
so what you do is you you install a web
application firewall
and you configure the web application
firefall to identify malicious queries
and stop them at the firewall level
itself so they never reach the
application
and thus the vulnerabilities of the
application don't get executed
buy better software and keep on updating
the software so
it's not necessary that once you have a
software you install it
it's going to be safe for life new
vulnerabilities are discovered every day
every hour and it may so happen what is
secure today
may be completely insecure tomorrow or
the day after
right so you need to keep on upgrading
the software
if there are no upgrades available and
the vulnerability still exists
you might want to migrate to a better
software and thus
ensure that you don't get hacked right
always update and use patches
organizations keep on sending out
updates and patches as and when they are
released you need to install them
to enhance your security postures
and then continuously monitor sql
statements and databases use
protocol monitors uh use different
softwares use the firewalls
to keep on monitoring what kind of
queries you're uh getting and based on
those queries
you want to ensure the inputs and the
queries that are creating
uh are not detrimental to the health of
the software that you have
so the key takeaways that we have seen
here in a nutshell are
what is the sequel injection attack we
have seen the types of sql injection
attack
how the how it works and how to prevent
sql injection attack
uh now we have done a couple of demos if
you want to know more
uh please comment in the comment section
of this video get in touch with us and
we can definitely help you
uh with more deeper insights into what
the sql injection attack is
that's it for this video i'll see you in
the next uh thank you and take care
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here